welcome back everybody harvey blankfeld
is back with a sneak peek of our las
vegas real estate market
and this podcast take a look
[Music]
welcome to our show this is las vegas
real estate now where we bring you the
three e's educate empower and engage we
want to help you make your real estate
decisions wise ones for you and your
family i'm your host harvey blankfeld
from the blankfeld group
at berkshire hathaway home services and
today i want to talk to you about
multiple offers how they affect buyers
and sellers but before i do i want to
introduce a special guest
we have rocky theos here from las vegas
now welcome rocky thank you this is oh
let me put my
let me put my earphones on here yes
you're actually gonna yeah you're gonna
hear it's really
wow okay i'm getting the feel usually
you're in studio or
we're you know on location at a home but
now i get a sneak peek at the video yeah
we're bringing you to a remote studio
it's not like channel 8 but it's fun
it is it is it's very nice it's very
nice so let's talk about the market
what's going on
okay so right now everyone's dealing
with multiple offers
we don't have very much inventory
inventories is at the lowest point it's
been in more than a decade
and what happens is that buyers are
struggling to find homes they like
and so this past weekend actually i was
out with a buyer we looked at eight
homes
seven of the homes we had to wait in
line to get into the home wow
and so you're talking about multiple
offers at home for buyers what it means
is when you're writing your offers
try to make them as a as aggressive as
you can comfortably
don't go beyond your budget but make
them as aggressive as you can so you can
get the
get the deal and it's not always price
either look at other terms within the
offer to make sure that you're
appealing to the seller the seller likes
your offer compared to all of your
fellow
buyers who you're trying to compete with
from the seller's perspective it's
important to have an
agent who knows how to discern one offer
from the other and be able to compare
and contrast them
right so i want i want sellers out there
to make sure they hire somebody
in this market particularly who has some
experience with that that's really
important right now so harvey what's the
difference between working with a real
estate team
and just an independent agent well with
an independent agent you're dealing with
one person throughout the transaction
what there are some advantages to that
you don't have to worry about who you're
talking but with a team you're getting a
variety of people with a variety of
specialties
we all we all bring different things to
the table either geographic specialties
or specialties within a certain segment
of the market with our team we've been
doing this a long time we have over a
century of experience we've got a lot of
experiences we bring a lot to the table
for our clients i don't want people to
just look for the the least expensive uh
realtor so i think
it pays dividends and you actually get a
bigger check if you're a seller
when you have somebody representing you
who's going to get your max dollars and
you're going to get a better deal as a
buyer when you have somebody who knows
how to deal with sellers and
in a multiple offer market well yeah
harvey i think you kind of know what
you're talking about
even if you even have a podcast so let's
talk about the podcast and
and what people can you know expect when
they tune in yeah you know we do las
vegas real estate now we've been on the
radio
on kdwn every saturday at 11. we have a
variety of guests on
experts in the real estate field you can
follow us on facebook we have a
ld real estate radio uh on facebook and
you can follow us live as we report on
wednesdays at one
give harvey and his team a call at
702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestateradio.com we'll be right
back